il est désormais l'heure d'accueillir de
social je suis très heureuse de la voir
parce que c'est quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien fait partie de la
famille touche pas à mon poste la
famille c'est que de la télé la famille
s'est vite quoi merci d'applaudir à
gâteau pro mais ce n'est que de la télé
vous êtes ravissante femme et bruce
ivins côté vous voit donc ce qu'on va
faire on va faire genre non ou alors on
se tutoie les ans tutoie on se tutoie
parce que c'est ridicule les gens savent
très bien que l'on se connaît
agathe tu viens parce que tu viens de
sortir aux éditions albin michel
tout va bien un livre dans lequel tu
reviens sur le cancer qui est à toucher
l'année dernière une maladie que tu
avais d'abord passer sous silence tu
n'en avais parlé à personne avant de le
dévoiler un petit peu plus tard à nous
l'équipe de ses 8 et puis et puis sur
les réseaux sociaux donc première
question pour quelle raison ce que tu as
eu envie besoin en vie ont besoin ou les
deux ou un autre de coucher cette
histoire sur le papier alors la première
raison elle était très égoïste spirent
est très personnel je commençais à
perdre de plus en plus mes cheveux bien
commencé à recevoir un petit peu je
commençais à avoir des commentaires sur
instagram agathe est ce que tu vas bien
t'es peut-être en dépression tu as l'air
fatigué tu as un peu moins de cheveux
etc
donc les gens arriver à percevoir ce que
moi je pensais encore imperceptible et
puis tout simplement c'était devenu un
petit peu malsain de de le dissimuler
parce que j'avais donc cette vie à
l'hôpital qui était donc de gérer ce
cancer le traitement etc
et j'avais de l'autre côté cette
pression que je me mettais sur les
épaules qui était cette pression de la
dissimulation à tout prix je devais
faire comme si tout allait bien comme si
ma vie n'avait absolument pas changé
alors que ce n'était pas le cas donc un
moment où j'ai eu se souvient se
reprenait exactement ce besoin de vérité
donc j'ai fait la démarche de le de
l'annoncer sur instagram
alors ils ont lu son livre avec
évidemment beaucoup d'attention qu'ils
te connaissent donc il est ils ont
dévoré le livre ils ont des questions à
te poser on va commencer par gilles ton
livre est beau parce qu'il est il est
écrit aveux de manière ciselé il est
très émouvant et il ya quelqu'un qui est
très présent dans le livre
quelqu'un qui t'a aidé dans la détection
de la maladie que tu as subi c'est cyril
hanouna tu en parles beaucoup dans le
livre est ce que tu peux nous expliquer
en quoi il t'a aidé tout au long de
cette épreuve alors comme tu l'as dit
très justement j lycée
c'est un petit peu grâce à lui que la
maladie a été décelée en tout cas ce
stade là parce que j'avais commencé les
explorations santé en voyant un premier
médecin puis un deuxième qui m'avait
prescrit tour à tour une radio des
poumons une échographie plein de prise
de sang ce n'était pas le bon examen
donc on mettait pas le doigt sur ce qui
n'allait pas et cyril a énormément
insisté on connaît tous ici il est
extrêmement un poids lourd il est lourd
on peut le dire
le thé est là il a eu raison qui m'a dit
faut absolument que tu ailles voir mon
père on peut pas rester comme ça il faut
qu'on ait des réponses claires et c'est
effectivement le docteur hanouna qui m'a
prescrit le bon scannell docteur a
menacé le père c'est pas leurs victimes
ils ont le même nom de famille et donc
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça qu'on
a qu'on a pu qu'on a pu aller dans le
bon sens et détecter la maladie au stade
2 sur 4 ce qui était quand même une
chance je pense dans mon cas est ce
qu'il faut ça veut dire que si il
n'avait pas eu cette chance de rencontre
d'avoir un producteur un ami qui s
intéressent et qui lui-même un parent
médecin il y aurait pu avoir un errement
du diagnostic pendant longtemps comme ça
parce que c'est beau premièrement un peu
exagérément j'ai je disais moi beaucoup
de témoignages de deux jeunes de mon âge
c est moi ça a mis 6 9 mois avant qu'on
avant qu'on mettre un mot sur cette
maladie peut être que quand il avait
détecté un problème il était au stade 1
ou 2 et finalement ça ça un petit peu
dégénéré et par la suite syrie comme
c'est mon producteur moi je tenais
absolument à continuer à travailler
donc j'avais dit s'il te plaît laisse
moi faire au moins une émission balances
ton post une fois par semaine et il m'a
dit bien sûr tant que tu te sens tu
seras toujours la bienvenue
donc il m'a beaucoup aidé on a adapté
mon emploi du temps en fonction est
effectivement de ce côté là c'était
cette étape alors francesca également
une caisse agathe au début de ta maladie
a décidé de garder le silence il y avait
que très peu de personnes autour de toi
qui était au courant et même avec les
colocs tes collègues de tpm pet a décidé
de rien dire ouais pourquoi est-ce que
tu avais peur de fausse compassion par
exemple tu avais peur de quoi en fait en
en gardant le silence bas effectivement
j'avais peur de recevoir cette espèce de
pitié cette espèce de d'empathie un
petit peu forcé la pauvre a gâté les
malades auxquels est peut-être moins
compétents donc il faut être très gentil
avec lcd
c'est le sentiment que je ne savais pas
comment gérer
donc je m'étais dit que c'était plus
simple de ne rien laisser paraître
est ce que j'ai encore deux mois est ce
que c'est parce que toi qui ne savaient
pas comment j'ai fait ou est ce que tu
t'es dit presque par altruisme pour les
autres les gens ne savent pas comment
gérer quelqu'un de malade donc on sait
c'est vrai que nous on ne sait jamais
s'il est dans le lit père au pâtis vous
ci est dans l'hyper distance en faisant
comme si de rien n'était et dans les
deux cas on a tout faux c'est vrai et
c'est ce que m'ont dit beaucoup
d'infirmières que j'ai rencontré c'est
effectivement moi je suis malade et est
donc je dois vis ma maladie comme je
l'entends mais c'est également dure à
appréhender pour tout mon entourage qui
ne s'est effectivement jamais trop
comment se positionner de quelle façon
comment comment gérer sa présence avec
moi son soutien par exemple quand on en
voit tous les jours qu'on voit tous les
jours ça va par sms j'ai des potes qui
faisait ça c'est insupportable
sa part d'une c'est pourquoi sinon il ya
des jours où ça va pas il ya deux jours
j'ai pas envie de leur répondre c'est
c'est vrai que c'est difficile à doser
nathalie alors vous avez tout de suite
dit le mot cancer alors c'est vrai que
certaines personnes préfèrent lui donner
un surnom comme le crabe ou autres et
souvent moi j'ai entendu qu'il est
atteint d'une longue maladie et c'est
pour ça que moi aussi j'ai écrit un
cancer sur le cancer en phase pour que
ça ne soit plus taboue et pour dire que
ce n'est pas une maladie honteuse alors
trouvez vous aussi comme moi que c'est
important de nommer le jeu veut dire le
mot parce que il faut rappeler vous me
nathalie également il avait oui et
d'ailleurs c'est elle m'a énormément
touché dans son livre parce que je me
suis vraiment retrouvé j'ai eu les mêmes
problèmes moi j'ai dû voir huit médecins
manquent qu'on me dise ce que j'avais et
heureusement que j'étais une battante
parce que sinon j'étais morte chez moi
l'après midi 1 1 chez moi donc mais
bravo pour ce que tu fais vraiment
choquant à cela me touche énormément
il est très attaché au goût assez que
voilà que je sais qu'il aime la
littérature que tu aimes les mots et
c'est pas un mots anodins tu aurais pu
effectivement choisir ou un autre nom
quand will come on apprivoise ray un
animal de compagnie presque ou carrément
le loonie en utilisant des perdants
allait villalon maladie ouais j'ai
choisi d'utiliser le mot cancer
je pense que c'est plus c'est plus juste
et effectivement je pense comme le dit
nathalie assez
assez justement c'est important de le
nommer tel qu'il est c'est important de
ne pas trop le dédramatiser
on peut on ne peut le raconter de façon
très factuelle sans tomber dans un
pathos ans en faire pleurer autour de
nos etc
mais le raconter le raconter dans dans
son entièreté dans exactement ce qu'il
est sans au féminisme sans le crac
beaucoup autour de moi à plélo grave
j'ai même des amis que vous aimez déjà
moins à l'époque
voilà qui se reflétaient de prononcer le
mot cancer j'entends je cours je leur en
parler arrête de dire cancer je n'aime
pas ce mot là oui mais c 'est c'est ce
que j'ai la réalité des chèques tenant
ce que j'ai et je pense que le fait de
l'appeler cancer qui est qui et ce qui
est exactement ça permet de se
l'approprier de l'appréhender et de
mieux guérir saeed al agha les
démangeaisons répond être plus justement
way par ailleurs vous dire vous avez
parié dessus
j'étudie les choses presque crûment les
étudie moi je voulais voir les choses en
face donc le cancer j'appelle ça un
cancer et tu en veux d'ailleurs même aux
médecins à un moment et à ceux qui
viennent te poser ton fameux cathéter
qu'on voit d'ailleurs sur la couverture
de son livre que je comprends monterait
à l'image que tu n'as pas cherché à
dissimuler sur cet hymne de de ton livre
en dix ans j'aurais voulu qu'on me dise
non c'est pas anodin non va me faire
quelque chose qui va se voir plutôt
qu'on essaie de dédramatiser qu'on nous
dise des choses non pas du tout va bien
se passer du maariv ouais bah rien
sentir alors pas mal et tu verras pas
absolument pas de mensonge quoi ahmad
mensonges et pains pâtes d'atténuation
parce que du coup comme comme nous on
est plongé dans un monde complètement
inconnu en europe
en tout cas pour moi qu'il est l hôpital
les traitements les protocoles de son la
chimiothérapie la maladie etc
on n'a aucun repère donc quand en face
de nous le personnel soignant l'expert
la personne h en étant nous dit tu vas
voir c'est une opération complètement
anodine tu ne va rien sentir ce sera une
incision va rien voir du tout tu
t'attends exactement à ça et quand tu es
confronté à la réalité de la chose que
tu es couché sur l'a6 au bloc opératoire
et que tu ressens une douleur horrible
donc pour une personne ne t'avais
prévenu
effectivement la le gouffre il est tu
leur en a voulu
ah oui j'étais très énervé c'est
d'ailleurs cette
c'est très étonnant parce que enfin
c'est très étonnant non mais j'imagine
que les personnes qui ont connu la
maladie comme toi le cancer comme toi on
sont passés par toutes ces phases des
mots souhait c'est à dire à la fois il
ya de la colère pas de la résignation
puis à nouveau une envie de se battre
donc c'est vraiment des montagnes russes
émotionnelles tout en quoi ouais on est
on est on est un petit peu à fleur de
peau mais voilà jean michel a également
une question de l'entourage c'est super
important dans toutes les maladies et
puis on voit bien dans ton livre que ta
mère a été très présente et que ton père
a joué un rôle particulier est ce que tu
peux nous parler de ça y a un rapport
particulier au père oui c'est un rapport
pratiquement inexistant ou et c'est vrai
que j'ai pas énormément de contacts avec
mon père ce qui ne s'est pas révélé la à
l'aune de la maladie c'est sa date de
bien avant mes parents ont divorcé quand
j'étais au collège et on a pas et on n'a
pas vraiment gardé contact
donc c'est vrai que face à l' annonce de
cette maladie mais je peux comprendre
lui-même son son malaise parce qu'avec
une fille avec qui il n'a pas est
vraiment de relations ça ne s'appelle
pas se voit une fois par an apprendre
une nouvelle d'une telle brutalité se
positionner face à ça je comprends qu'il
était mal à l'aise je comprends qu'il se
soit réfugié dans derrière des blagues
derrière l'alcool c'était le réveillon
de noël je comprends que ça a été dur
pour lui à assumer et émois de la même
façon recevoir des effusions d'amour de
la part de ce papa qui n'en était plus
vraiment ça m'aurait mis mal à l'aise
également satory bien mal à l'aise ou au
fond de toi tu aurais souhaité quand
même que à tous à tout malheur il ya
quelques il ya quelque chose de positif
peut être éventuellement ce cancer là
vous auriez vous aurez tous vous
rapprocher non je pense que les choses
sont à leur place j'ai pas de si si je
devais réécrire l'histoire je pense que
je la réécrire exactement de cette façon
là je pense qu'il n'y a pas je n'avais
pas d'attentes en tenir est ce que tu as
été surprise parce que parfois quand on
traverse des épreuves
on est agréablement surpris par des gens
dont on n'imaginait pas qu'il viendrait
être proche de nous et à linverse des
gens dont on se disait bombe à lui s'il
m'arrive anglais qui sera toujours là et
bars
abonnés absents il ya plus personne
est-ce que tu as connu c'est ce que tu
vas c'est vrai que c'est un révélateur
extrêmement puissant sur soi même et sur
les autres effectivement ça ça opère un
tri naturel et sélective
imparable et effectivement c'est
exactement ce que tu as dit j'ai des
potes je pensais qu'ils allaient être
d'un d'une présence et d'un soutien
indéfectible qui au final était très
auto centrée sur les petits problèmes de
travail sur ledit problème de meuf de
mecs bien mais maintenant je pense parce
qu'ils se refusent parce qu'ils ont peur
parce que la maladie fait peur ouais
donc il refuse et au contraire j'ai une
amie alix qui n'était pas ma plus
proches amis qui elle veut voulais être
là chaque séance de chimio qui m'a
accompagné et qui s'est révélé être tout
d'un coup extrêmement présents ouais
c'est dans ces moments là qu'on on
découvre des amitiés fortes et qu'elles
sont pour le coup indéfectible tu sais
que dans l'émission que tu suis
évidemment régulièrement et bien sûr le
cinquième chronique voilà il ya la
fameuse rubrique des questions du
cinquième chroniqueur donc on avoue on
s'est dit qu'on allait faire ben
proposer à nos téléspectateurs de te
poser des questions en direct soir et je
les ai là elle arrive au fur et à mesure
et où j'ai une première question d'une
jeune fille qui s'appelle justin savait
juste il dit bonjour pour déjà à
l'épaule il te dis bonjour le fait de
nous avoir raconté votre histoire à
aider des personnes à le faire qu'avez
vous ressenti par rapport à cela
moi je vous trouve très forte et
courageuse d'avoir parlé de votre
histoire est belle vie à vous merci
justin
oui le fait que peut-être tourner ton
message à aider d'autres gens cette jupe
il imagina jeu je l'imaginais absolument
pas mais je les ressentis dès lors que
j'ai fait ce poste instagram somme toute
très factuelle mais rassurant et encore
aujourd'hui je regardais mais médée m
sur instagram et il y avait un jeune qui
me dit qu'il avait un cancer lui de la
peau et qu'il a acheté mon livre pour
pour essayer de lire le témoignage de
quelqu'un qui vit des la maladie à son
âge etc et il fait merci parce que grâce
à toi je commence à en parler il m'avait
même pas parlé à ses parents par exemple
et dans ce cas là on se dit qu'on a bien
fait d'écrire un livre
oui parce que là je n'arrive pas contre
une seule personne qui aimait à se
sentir mieux et pareillement les
remerciements des infirmières aussi
c'est vrai alors la chaîne question d'un
garçon qui s'appelle pierre fier dit
voilà salut pierre agathe cela fait
longtemps que tu ne poses plus de photos
de ton chéri sur instagram est ce que
cela veut dire que tu es maintenant à
coeur à prendre visiblement pierre est
sur les rangs mais sur le poker le
bouquin qu'est ce qu'on dit à pierre
prend un numéro voilà que sa blonde
mauvaise déduction ça veut simplement
dire que j'ai appris à préserver ma vie
intime
alors justement ça amène la question de
flou alors qui dit est-ce que des choses
ont changé dans ta vie après le cancer
est-ce que effectivement du coup tu as
vu de la ville de façon différente et
pris peut-être des résolutions comme tu
sais ce que tu as nous dire voilà
maintenant je cloisonne plus bassam à
l'inde et des apprentissages que j'ai
fait au cours de de cette maladie et
après c'est que je me sous-estimer
énormément et je pense qu'on se
sous-estiment tous quand on vous annonce
qu'on a un cancer on s'imagine tout de
suite l'enfer de la chimio les
vomissements et tout effectivement c'est
très dur mais je pense que on a tous en
nous une force tu te découverte
guerrière ouais on n'a pas le choix on a
une bataille je suis forcément quand on
est acculé le gisant au pied du mur
c'est là qu'on révèle une nature
extrêmement puissante que moi je ne
soupçonnais pas donc maintenant rien ne
semble impossible possible voilà on a
une battante avec no mercy
[Applaudissements]